we've got 12x to the third y to the
third plus 16x to the fourth y plus 10xy
all of that divided by 4xy
so there's several ways to think about
them they're all equivalent this is
going to be the exact same thing we
essentially can kind of separate the
numerators this is the same thing as
12 x to the third
y to the third
over 4 x y
plus
16 x to the fourth y
over 4 x y
plus 10
x y over
4 x y and there's multiple ways to think
about it one is if i add if i have a
plus b over c this is clearly the same
thing as a over c plus b over c we're
just adding the we're taking the
fraction apart if we did it reverse we
would just be adding fractions the other
way to think about is that we're
distributing the division we're dividing
this whole thing by 4xy so we divide
each of the terms by 4xy the last way to
think about it which is really the same
thing is that we're multiplying this
whole thing times 1 over 4xy so we're
distributing the 1 over 4xy times
everything which is the same thing as
dividing by 4xy either way we get to
this and we just have to simplify this
really just using exponent properties
so we can divide 12 12 divided by 4 is
pretty straightforward that is just 3.
so let me just write it this way so 12
divided by 4 is 3 so that gives us a 3.
x squared divided by x
remember x is the same thing as x to the
first power so that's going to be x
that's going to be x to the 3 minus 2
this is going to be x to the 3 minus 2
power sorry x to the 3 minus 1 power
this is 1 over here 3 minus 1 power
which would be x
squared
and then finally you have y to the third
divided by y
well that's just divided by y to the one
and so y to the third divided by y to
the one is going to be y squared three
minus one is two
now let's do the next term plus
we have sixteen over four
sixteen over four is just four
that is just equal to four
then we have x to the fourth
over x
well once again x is just is the same
thing as x to the first so this is going
to be x to the 4 minus 1 or x to the
third power and then finally we have y
divided by y well that's just going to
be 1.
so we don't have to write it down we
could write one or right here but that
won't do much won't change the value so
just these guys essentially cancel out
and then finally if plus
10 divided by four they're both
divisible by two so it becomes five
halves
so that part over there simplifies to
five over two
so plus
five halves and then x divided by x well
those just cancel out that's just one y
divided by y well that's just one as
well so we're just left with 5 halves
and we're done this whole expression
simplified to 3x squared y squared plus
4x to the third
plus 5 halves